fat scan is a very useful scan in  identifying the tumor in the body now  over here in this pet image or positron  emission tomography image you can easily  see the tumor but over here the one main  problem is that the resolution is image  of the solo that you cannot identify the  proper anatomical structure where the  tumor is to solve this problem  scientists have come out with something  known as a PET CT scan where they merge  a CT scan and a pet image so over here  you can clearly get the anatomical  details as well as the tumor so over  here you get to identify the tumor as  well as you get to identify the exact  location of the tumor that is anatomy to  learn more about Pet City and pet scan  watch the entire video on our Channel